president biden is said to be improving
as his battle with covet enters a third
day the president's physician says his
symptoms are waning after a full day of
treatment with the antiviral drug
paxlovid and tylenol noticeably hoarse
the president joined a virtual meeting
on gas prices friday dr kevin o'connor
says the 79 year old president who is
vaccinated and boosted has a normal
pulse blood pressure respiratory rate
and oxygen saturation he did stop short
of providing specific metrics for more
on the president's condition and the
state of the pandemic in the country we
are joined now by the president's chief
medical advisor dr anthony fauci dr
fauci i want to start with the president
there are two things there we've also
seen him working masked and unmasked so
a question about maybe the messaging
that we're seeing with the masking and
what more can you tell us if anything
about the president's condition
well first of all the president is doing
really quite well
i had a long conversation last night at
around 10 o'clock with dr kevin o'connor
who's the primary physician for the
president and the president continues to
improve he's putting in a full day of
work virtually and as each day goes by
he's doing he's doing fine so as we've
said before given the fact that he's
been vaccinated doubly boosted and is
receiving
uh pax levid a drug which clearly goes a
long way to preventing progression of
disease we fully expect that he's going
to be doing very well with regard to
masking when the president is in the
presence of people who are doing things
around him
for one reason or other he'll put a mask
on when you see him without a mask then
he's following the cdc recommendations
so we're seeing the spike in these
omicron sub-variants ba-4 ba-5 if this
is what we're going to be seeing is our
big summer coved wave what can we expect
well it's very difficult to predict one
of the things that we're obviously
seeing is that we're averaging around
reported about 140 000 cases which is
likely a
rather significant undercount it's
probably several fold more than that
because many people
get infected have mild to moderate
symptoms and don't report it the thing
we're concerned about is that
hospitalizations are going up we're
having about 40 000 people
in the hospital and we're still at
around 300 to 400 deaths
that's something that is a level that is
really not acceptable so before talking
about in additional spikes we need to be
concerned about
and do something about what's going on
right now
is an uptick in cases we've got to get a
better control of that and we have ways
of doing that people need to get
vaccinated people who are up for their
booster
should get boosted when you're in an
indoor setting and in a location a
jurisdiction that has a high level of
viral dynamics you should be wearing a
mask indoors those are the kind of
things we can do
to prevent even more of an uptick in
cases than we're seeing right now
dr fauci it does seem like a lot of
people right now are treating this like
a cold not not one you want to get but
you get sniffles for a couple days you
feel tired
then you're better not everyone of
course but that does seem to be the way
a lot of people feel about this right
now is that the right or wrong approach
and then what are you expecting in the
fall
you know i believe ultimately we're
we're not going to eliminate or
eradicate this virus we're going to have
to live with it
because it's the virus that has such a
degree of transmissibility
that it's not going to just disappear
however we are not at that point now
when you have 40 000 people in the
hospital you have hundreds of thousands
of people getting infected and you have
three to 400 deaths we're going to get
to a point where we'll have to go along
and not have this disrupt the social
order but it is premature
to think we don't have a problem to deal
with because although we'd like the
virus to be behind us in the rearview
mirror as we say
the virus is not acting that way
right now and we can do something about
that as i just mentioned there are
things we can do
to bring down that level
so although we would all like to be free
of the virus we're not free of it yet
we're going to have to learn to live
with it but we've got to do better than
we're doing right now
an ever-changing virus and it is our new
normal dr anthony fauci thank you so
much